interviews are part of any actor's life
sometimes if everything goes perfectly a
great interview can even change a
celebrity's legacy for good
but sometimes they go horribly awkwardly
and unforgettably wrong
these are some of the worst ever
conducted
one of the most recognizable examples of
an actor interview gone wrong occurred
in april 2015 when robert downey jr was
promoting avengers
age of ultron channel 4's krishnan guru
murthy who was already known for making
his interviewees uncomfortable
initially asked downey easy questions
about the movie and his character
alarms started to go off however when
guru murthy brought up a downy quote
from a previous new york times interview
you can't go from a two thousand dollar
a night hotel suite
to a penitentiary and understand it and
come out a liberal
downey then responded are we promoting a
movie
the interview ended on a dour note when
downey walked out after guru murthy
prodded him
about his complicated relationship with
his father robert downey senior and his
past history with addiction
shortly after the interview was
published guru murthy wrote about the
incident for the guardian clarifying
that question areas were discussed ahead
of time with downey's publicist
and claimed channel 4 news did not do
quote promotional interviews
downey on the other hand vented to radio
talk show host howard stern about his
less than ideal experience calling guru
murthy a quote
clown among other things for over 60
years larry king made a name for himself
as one of the most prolific talk show
hosts of all time
he's a fixture of american television
about as familiar to small screen
viewers as friends reruns
but his rocky 2007 interview with
all-star comedian jerry seinfeld
was certainly not a highlight in his
career the seinfeld co-creator and star
appeared on cnn's larry king live to
promote the dreamworks animation film
b-movie which he co-wrote produced and
starred in
king who cameoed in b-movie asked
seinfeld if his flagship sitcom was
cancelled and the following response was
anything but enthusiastic that was the
number one show on television larry you
were
year later in an interview on the young
turks king admitted that he
only got to know seinfeld's sitcom work
later and
regretted asking what turned out to be
an ill-informed question
despite this setback king continued to
interview other high-profile celebrities
on larry king live
and larry king now the latter of which
began airing on
king's aura tv starting in 2012.
ryan seacrest has been involved in many
awkward moments throughout his career as
a celebrity host
one of his most cringe-worthy moments
involved none other than robert
pattinson
while the british actor has since
starred in several high-profile indie
films such as 2017's good time and
2019's the lighthouse
pattinson first gained worldwide stardom
for portraying soulful vampire edward
cullen in the big screen adaptations of
stephanie meyer's massively popular
twilight novels
seacrest interviewed pattinson in 2009
at the premiere of the twilight sequel
new moon for his radio talk show on air
with ryan seacrest
this two-minute interview started off
smoothly enough but things turned sour
when seacrest asked
what do you say to your fans who are
desperate to know
about you and your co-star kristen
pattinson's publicist subsequently came
in and ended the interview before the
teen heartthrob could answer the
question
pattinson amidst laughter told seacrest
to quote watch new moon and promptly
left the studio seacrest's question
arrived during a moment of particularly
intense scrutiny for the twilight stars
around this time rumors were circulating
heavily about the potential real-life
romance between pattinson and his
co-star kristen stewart
despite this speculation neither
pattinson nor his publicity team wanted
to give any official details to the
press
thankfully pattinson and seacrest would
reunite in 2011 to discuss the actor's
latest movie
water for samuel elephants jackson has
starred in a vast variety of terrific
movies throughout his career
the sheer number of stone cold hits in
his filmography
is stunning the man has been iconic in
pulp fiction
the incredibles snakes on a plane the
mcu and star wars making him one of the
most famous people on the planet
yet an entertainment reporter still
confused him with another famous actor
during a 2014 interview
the first question that ktla's sam rubin
asked jackson who was promoting the 2014
robocop remake he starred in
was about the reaction to a then recent
super bowl commercial
which featured lawrence fishburne not
jackson
once jackson realized what was going on
he did not hold back not lawrence
pitchburg
that's my fault i know that that was my
fault uh my mistake you know what
we don't all look alike ruben admitted
his mistake and tried to steer the
conversation to robocop
rubin quickly issued an apology calling
his flub a
quote amateur mistake the reporter
revealed that he'd interviewed jackson
several times before
and that he saw him in a super bowl ad
for captain america the winter soldier
which is what confused him
though he still described the grief he
took as quote well deserved
fortunately jackson and ruben met again
during the winter soldier press junket
and jackson didn't even recognize ruben
until he brought up the incident
jane fonda has gained fame as both an
actress and an
outspoken activist but she looked
visibly irritated when someone brought
up a taboo subject
that someone was megan kelly who
interviewed fonda and robert redford
about their film
our souls at night back in 2017
this conversation which aired on the nbc
talk show megyn kelly today was going
well
until kelly told fonda you admit you've
had work done
which i think is to your credit but you
look amazing
the veteran actress glared at the talk
show host while she asked the question
and then responded
we really want to talk about that the
glare itself became a widespread meme
after fonda called out kelly in several
future interviews kelly finally
addressed this moment on january 22nd
2018.
for years she has spoken openly about
her joy in giving a cultural
face to older women well the truth is
most older
women look nothing like fonda kelly then
spoke about the actress's controversial
vietnam war history
is that relevant to the conflict at hand
not really which is why so many found
the moment petty
london-born cara delevingne has
established a successful career in
acting
and modeling but a catastrophic
interview on good day sacramento is
likely not a moment she wants to look
back on
co-host marianne mcclary started things
off badly when she introduced the
actress who was appearing to promote her
movie paper towns as
carla delevingne the same host then
asked delevine if she'd read the book
the film is based on to which she
sarcastically responded
no i never read the book all the script
actually i kind of winged it
delevine looked visibly uncomfortable
throughout the interview but still tried
to make the most out of a sticky
situation
unfortunately all three hosts had
already noticed that the actress model
looked irritated and mccleary told
delevingne near the end of the interview
we'll let you go then how about that you
go take a little nap maybe get a red
bull how about that
delevine subsequently offered the hosts
one more perplexed look before
her satellite feed cut off mcclary
wasn't done
even then declaring that delevine was
quote in a mood
later that day delevine tweeted some
people just don't understand sarcasm or
the british sense of humor
a truly excruciating example of
reporters being ill-prepared for an
interview occurred in 2014
when kwgn tv's chris parente
interviewed kristen wiig and bill hader
about their film the skeleton twins
the conversation was going fairly well
until the high-spirited parente
made a disastrous and odd attempt at a
joke
he asked wig i am thinking on this
program of doing the news
uh completely full frontal completely
nude
do you recommend that do you have advice
for going nude
wig looked confused as anyone would
offering a few awkward chuckles while
hater wore
an openly incredulous look on his face
perente attempted to salvage his joke
pointing out that wig had a nude scene
in this film wig
immediately clarified that she was
actually nude in a different movie
welcome to me and definitely not in the
skeleton twins
hater joked i'm nude in this movie
and leaning into the absurdity of the
moment claimed that the film took place
on mars
hater then openly asked parente if he'd
seen the skeleton twins and the reporter
knowing he was beyond saving claimed
that haters character wins the lottery
and the movie has
muppets neither claim is true of course
this viral moment was very embarrassing
for parente but he
interviewed hader again in 2015 to talk
about a movie appropriately titled
train wreck the pair joked around the
whole time
a 2012 interview between jerry panakoli
of extra
and anne hathaway proves just how creepy
interviewers can be toward actors
penicolli had already asked scarlett
johansson earlier that year if she wore
underwear while in her skintight
avengers costume and asked similar
questions of hathaway about her
appearance as catwoman in the dark
knight rises
in fact penicolli started the interview
with a comment about how hathaway had to
be in perfect shape for this role
hathaway responded it wasn't about being
in perfect shape it was about being able
to
do the stunts and the fighting perfectly
pinnacley pressed on with a question
about the costume specifically
hathaway replied it was form-fitting um
i mean it's not a pair of sweatpants i
wouldn't describe it as that kind of
comfortable but um
you know it was it was fine the next
question from pinacoli was about
hathaway's quote
feline fitness regimen hathaway laughed
it off and dismissed the topic as quote
boring but penicoli kept pressing until
hathaway shot back
are you trying to lose weight well
what's what's the deal man you look
great no no no
no seriously we have to talk about this
what what do you want are you trying to
fit into a cat suit
hathaway joked around towards the end
but penicoli was still in the wrong for
swamping the actress with inappropriate
questions about her weight
and not asking about the movie mark
wahlberg's appearance on the graham
norton show is a rare example of an
actor being at fault for a bad interview
norton is known to give his guests
alcohol but when wahlberg appeared on
the show in february 2013
alongside sarah silverman and michael
fassbender audiences
could tell he'd had a bit too much to
drink the interview
started off smoothly as wahlberg
discussed his latest film
broken city and even told stories about
his children as the episode went on
however wahlberg participated in several
crazy antics such as flirting with
silverman challenging fassbender over
penis size and outright groping norton
ironically wahlberg offered some big
flashing warning signs early on when he
said why would you allow people to drink
alcohol and come on a show
wahlberg would later claim his antics on
the show were quote pre-planned
when speaking to digital spy about this
uncomfortable episode the following july
norton called wahlberg quote a lovely
guy who he didn't judge too much for
what he chalked up to quote jet lag and
wine in a later interview
wahlberg has continued to appear on the
graham norton show so there is
apparently no major animosity between
the two figures
or at least any they'll admit to on the
record
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrities are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one